fox news national security correspondent
jennifer
uh we're hearing spiraling out of
control which is obviously extremely
disturbing out of the u.n what can you
tell us
well laura what i can tell you is that
i'm watching images in uh downtown keeve
where there are uh where reporters are
showing what appear to be explode there
they say they're hearing explosions in
the capital of kiev this is what we have
been expecting we have been
we have been told that once the the
air strikes and missile strikes begin
that all of ukraine is in vladimir
putin's site i want to read to you what
putin said in his speech at 6 a.m this
morning when he announced
this military
action inside ukraine here's what he
said and it's very ominous in an
apparent warning to the united states
and nato he said in his address a couple
of words for those who would be tempted
to intervene russia will respond
immediately and you will have
consequences that you never have had
before in your history
i want to pick up on something that
lucas was talking about earlier as to
why it is that the u.s has not put
troops on the ground or flying um in the
airspace above ukraine it is very a very
different situation we find ourselves in
tonight because these are two nuclear
powers the u.s and nato know that when
you are talking about russia and russia
going into a sovereign country like
ukraine
it's not something where you can put
your military there on the ground and
risk it escalating into a nuclear war
and so that is why there's been a very
calibrated approach an attempt to warn
and declassify all this intelligence to
tell putin that we're watching we know
what he's doing uh it was a they've been
working on this since october the nato
alliance has been working on this
together that's why the sanctions are
ready to be rolling out they're going to
be rolling out in waves in the coming
days because they knew that they had
very few cards to stop putin if he
wanted to move his military position as
they watched steadily as he was doing
and so
very important to remember that that is
why troops are in the baltics and in the
nato article 5 countries they do not
want this to spill over into a war
between two nuclear powers secondly you
were talking earlier about yes go ahead
with laura now jennifer
the the question here is
where
are our nato allies in terms of you know
just statements we haven't seen
statements yet from germany at least i
haven't um france italy uh
it's a little surprising i haven't seen
anything coming out of obviously the
biggest power
yeah this do you mean this evening well
yeah i think look this has just happened
in the last few minutes they knew i i
mean everybody's intelligence suggested
that tonight uh in exactly in fact i had
heard the the timing of when we expected
this to begin this was an open secret
this was not exactly a surprise attack
that is occurring right now i think what
you are going to be seeing you see the
u.n security council that is right now a
bit of a kabuki dance with the russians
seated as the presidency of the rotating
presidency of the u.n security council
they will veto anything that the
security council says but at least you
heard the ambassadors there and you'll
hear the other ambassadors speaking and
speaking out eloquently about how this
is the gravest danger to europe since
world war ii this is a turning point in
terms of uh what is going to be
unleashed from putin going into ukraine
every american needs to understand that
this
is not a european conflict this the
world is too interconnected and as we
were talking about before president xi
is watching this i remember the images
at the beginning of the olympics when
president putin was sitting there and
the ukrainian uh national team comes
walking into the opening ceremony and he
he leaned back he closed his eyes and he
had total disdain he would not stand for
the ukraine uh team as they walked in
you knew at that moment that putin had
decided to invade ukraine and he was
just lying in weight and then he stood
for the russian team it was all about
this this uh the the platform that the
olympics gave for these two world
leaders president xi and president putin
to carve up the world and you can better
be
people better realize that president xi
is watching and that uh one of the
reasons the statements coming out of the
chinese league
in with regards to ukraine he has not
criticized putin has not criticized
russia he said it's an internal uh he
believes that internal matter should be
handled internally he's referencing
taiwan so this is a moment that the
world had better stand up and they
better realize what's happening tonight
because it is very dangerous
jennifer thank you we'll check back with
you